in the opening scene a boy awakens in a
hospital morgue lacking any recollection
of how he arrived there confused and
determined to escape he sneaks out of
the morgroom startling a nurse who
reacts with a scream following this he
has escorted to a ward room where he
sees a woman named Rudy who appears
concerned for him soon after the boy
loses Consciousness and upon waking he
once again tries to flee however this
time he is confronted by several people
who have a creepy look on their faces
desperate to escape all of these he
climbs out of a window and walks along
the ledge unfortunately he slips and
plummets from a considerable height but
before hitting the ground the building
mysteriously gets tilted enabling him to
stand on its side just then an
individual resembling a window cleaner
approaches him and introduces himself as
the guardian he discloses that the boy's
memory has been erased and he is now a
spirit who has been granted a second
chance at life the boy is inside the
body of men a teenager who recently
committed the unthinkable following this
Revelation the guard restores the
building to its original position
compelling men to clutch onto the
window's Edge Min somehow manages to
pull himself up and climbs in through
the window as he returns to his Ward
room a nurse walks in and tries to stab
him with an injection in response Min
hurls a saline bottle only to witness
its contents freeze midair the nurse
then unveils herself as the guardian who
seems to be able to possess any form the
guardian refers to min's body as a
temporary Homestay and gives him 100
days to uncover the reason behind min's
death warning that failure to do so will
result in his permanent demise he then
hands the boy an hourglass to keep track
of the 100 days the next morning the
doctor examines men and is astounded by
his recovery despite having been
deceased for a whole day nonetheless the
doctor considers it a positive sign and
discharges him from the hospital after
this Rudy who is none other than min's
mother drives him back home upon arrival
Min discovers that he has an older
brother named man who hates him for some
reason he also meets his father who
appears to have resigned from his
position as a university lecturer to
pursue a career in multi-level marketing
specifically selling supplements for the
time being Rudy asks men to share a room
with his brother since she doesn't want
to leave him alone just yet later men
inquires about the day he committed the
unthinkable but his mother refuses to
discuss it that night Min sneaks out of
his room and begins to explore the house
he sifts through numerous photo frames
and albums but fails to find any
pictures of himself he then heads to his
own room only to discover that it's
locked when Min tries to peek inside he
is caught by men who angrily sends him
back to bed the next day A desperate man
climbs out the window walks along the
ledge and breaks into his room but once
again he finds nothing but a photograph
of himself mentioning his birth and
death dates shortly after Rudy enters
the room and asks if he's about to do
something drastic again Min denies it
and inquires about his belongings to
which Rudy claims that he was the one
who disposed of everything soon after
she breaks down in tears embracing men
and asking why he took such a drastic
step the following morning Min decides
to continue his schooling while getting
dressed he discovers a brooch and his
mother's business card in his wallet
here it is revealed that Rudy is an
engineer working in a distant Province
later on she drives him to school and
before parting ways instructs men to
keep the truth hidden from everyone and
simply pretend to be absent due to flu
while at school he realizes that men has
very few friends with Lee being his only
close companion man also has a crush on
a fellow student named P who is a bright
student and his tutoring peer p is a
member of the card stunt Club so as men
as a result he attends their next
meeting where the leaders remind him
that he needs to complete their drawing
For an upcoming competition amidst this
Min notices other students wearing
brooches identical to the one he has in
his wallet he soon discovers that these
Bridges signify the exceptional students
of the Olympic class intrigued he
decides to wear the brooch and enters
the Olympic class but is swiftly caught
by the teacher and thrown back out later
Min meets p in the library to seek
academic assistance and finds himself
captivated by her beauty much like the
previous version of men reincarnate him
as many times as you want he will always
want the P gradually the spirit
inhabiting men's body begins to adapt to
his new life and grows comfortable he
spends a significant amount of time with
p and they both seem to enjoy each
other's company one day min's father
visits the school and reminds him about
an appointment with his therapist he
also provides men with some of his own
products to advertise later Min attends
the therapy session where the therapist
asks intrusive questions about men's
personal life but as the boy tries to
reply the therapist abruptly shatters a
product bottle causing its contents to
scatter in the air revealing himself as
the guardian it becomes apparent that
the guardian's purpose is to remind men
of his mission and advise him against
getting distracted the guardian
emphasizes the urgency of time running
out and tells men to uncover the truth
soon additionally he informs Min that
The Hourglass he previously gave to him
will automatically halt once he
discovers the truth in the next scene we
see the students are immersed in the
festivities at school but P appears to
be upset Min approaches her and
discovers that she is dad because she's
unable to solve certain questions p is
worried that she won't be able to
achieve a top-ranking medal this time
and fears disappointing everyone upon
hearing her distress Min attempts to
uplift her spirits with comforting words
he also asks if they're a couple but he
denies it explaining that he never asked
her out as the night progresses the two
have an enjoyable time together playing
games making wishes and admiring the
fireworks while sitting on a rooftop
taking in the view P remarks on how much
men has changed compared to his previous
self Min then asks her which version of
him she prefers to which she replies
that she will answer this after a few
days the following day at home Min
overhears his mother speaking on the
phone with his father she appears to be
enraged because the greedy man sold her
wedding ring for business purposes to
console his mother Minh joins her and
assists with some kitchen tasks a few
days later Min and P are sitting
together when P presents him with a gift
for his birthday it is a personally
crafted Kaleidoscope knowing that Min
has a fontness for such objects as they
Converse P brings up min's previous
Quest and shares that she prefers the
current version of men over his past
self finally their relationship blossoms
as they share a romantic kiss the next
day at school while Min is drawing pee
on a bridge he notices group pictures in
which the previous version of men can be
seen in the background of his subtle
Locker intrigued Min approaches the same
locker and forcefully opens it only to
find it empty moments later Lee
approaches him and informs him that he
had left his laptop in her locker a few
days earlier Lee further explains that
she went to min's place that day but
couldn't find his mother so she handed
the laptop to men after learning of this
Min hastily returns home and sneaks into
Men's Room in search of his laptop while
rummaging through the room he discovers
family photographs with his face
intentionally scratched on all of them
he also comes across paperwork
indicating men's desire to study abroad
eager to uncover more details Min checks
his brother's computer and stumbles upon
a conversation between man and his
ex-girlfriend as he goes through their
chat he learns that men blamed him for
being unable to pursue his studies
abroad it was because of men's sudden
attempts that his brother had to drop
all of his plans this is the reason why
men hates his brother so much he even
wishes that men never returned from the
hospital dad Manor such soon
after Min finds the S Note
written by his past self however before
he can delve into its contents men walks
in seizes the laptop and hurls it out
the window Min rushes outside retrieves
the damaged laptop and somehow manages
to turn it back on following this he
reads through his own S note and
discovers that he committed The
Unthinkable by ingesting a poisonous
substance in the note he expresses
intense hate towards his father who took
advantage of his mother's earnings and
his brother who consistently belittled
him the only person he truly trusted and
loved was his mother however she was so
busy that she never had time for him one
day Min visits the Olympic class to CP
he secretly observed through the doorway
and shockingly witnesses her teacher
touching her inappropriately much to his
astonishment P remains passive and does
not even retaliate the very next day Min
confronts the teacher and punches him
hard on his face before taking pee along
with him outside Min demands the truth
regarding their relationship he reveals
that she dislikes the teacher but
chooses to remain silent as it's the
only way that she can maintain her
academic Excellence furthermore P asks
men to apologize to her teacher as she
doesn't want to jeopardize her future
because of all of this consumed by anger
Min refuses to comply and storms off
afterwards min's father arrives at the
school and has to apologize on behalf of
his son later in the car he scolds men
for his actions in retaliation Min
confronts his father angrily
highlighting how he sold his mother's
wedding ring for his foolish business
ventures depressed by these events men
boards a bust to his mother's quarter in
another Province however his heart sinks
when he discovers his mother living with
her secret boyfriend unable to Bear the
weight of these shocking revelations all
at once Min runs away in tears and
stands alone on a bridge in the midst of
the rain after a brief moment the
Raindrop stops in the air and the
guardian disguised as a young girl
approaches him Min tells the guardian
that the complexity of his family and to
betrayal from pee are the reasons behind
his untimely demise however The
Hourglass symbolizing his quest for the
truth doesn't stop indicating that min's
answer is incorrect the guardian then
reminds him that he has three days
remaining to uncover the correct answer
and departs later Min returns home and
vents his frustration by destroying his
belongings in his room shortly
afterwards Lee visits him asking if he
has finished his drawing assignment
filled with rage Min responds rudely to
Lee he further claims that he never
cared for Lee since he didn't even
mention her name in his S note this
Revelation shatters Lee's heart as she
had never treated men with the same
disdain he experienced from the others
later in the evening men and his father
go to pick up Rudy from her workplace
after this the three go to a restaurant
to have dinner while they dine Min
pretends to use the restroom but keeps a
watchful eye on them from a distance
during this min's father Returns the
wedding ring to Rudy but instead of
accepting it she confesses about her
Affair which causes men's father to
storm off in Anger following this men
and his mother drive home together in
their car along the way she apologizes
to men acknowledging her mistake and
assuring him that she will prioritize
her family from now on however men's
anger remains unresolved leading him to
yell at his mother this distraction
causes her to lose focus while driving
resulting in their car getting hit by a
truck fortunately men only sustains
minor injuries but his mother's
condition appears to be critical in the
next scene Min returns home and
discovers some food left for him by his
mother he also looks at the gift P had
given him which triggers regret for his
previous Outburst this suddenly makes
him realize how much love and support
men had around him viewing Things From A
New Perspective he then Endeavors to
make the best of his remaining time
resolving past conflicts and tying up
Loose Ends finally he also completes his
drawing for his stunt Club the next day
the Olympic team is participating in a
tournament and before that P is called
upon to deliver a speech however seeing
men in the audience makes her feel
guilty so she runs away Min follows her
to the classroom and tries to comfort
her assuring her that he's not mad at
her anymore after a brief conversation
the two end up embracing each other
Bridging the gaps between them
encouraged P then goes to the principal
and fearlessly reports the teacher's
abuse aware of P's limited time for
drawing Min leaves his completed work on
her desk cheering her up for the
upcoming contest on his final day Min
expresses his apology to Lee for his
previous rude Behavior they then watch
rehearsals for the school's card stunt
competition in which Lee had submitted
one of men's old designs created by the
previous men as the card stunt is
unveiled it turns out to be exactly like
the one made by the new men with this it
finally Dawns on the boy that he was Men
in his previous life and a flood of
memories resurface suddenly he loses his
balance and falls down the stairs then
he experiences a vision of himself lying
in his room with the guardian for him in
this Vision he tells the guardian that
his death was his own faults as he had
refused to see the positive aspects of
Life The Guardian congratulates him on
his victory and discloses that the test
was a ruse to help him perceive the
truth he then tells men to embrace his
new life with a mindset of positivity
Min awakens once again on the school
stairs overwhelmed with joy and Embraces
Lee he then hurries to the hospital to
reunite with his mother and bridge the
gap between them starting from that day
Min resumes his daily routine living a
life filled with happiness and joy
surrounding him subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching